all right we begin with a fox news alert
rescue efforts are underway at mario
paul theater that was bombed by russian
forces yesterday they are estimating up
to 1 000 civilians had taken shelter
inside the building including children
at one point or another over the last 22
days but right now there are no reports
of any deaths extraordinarily yeah
that's a miracle jonathan hunt joins us
joins us live from western ukraine with
the latest jonathan
rachel steve brian we understand that
that urgent rescue effort is ongoing it
appears that at least a large part of
the shelter underneath that theater in
the southern city of mary opal survived
intact so rescuers are digging through
the rubble trying to move it off of the
shelter itself and get to those who may
have survived inside that
theater by the way was clearly marked
with the word children on both sides of
it as a sign to the russians do not hit
this building because it is being used
to shelter civilians including children
the russians bombed it anyway according
to ukrainian officials we're also seeing
disturbing video today out of the city
of chernahev that's just north of keeve
according to a tweet from the u.s
embassy here in ukraine russian soldiers
simply opened fire on people standing in
line to buy bread at least 10 people
killed in that apparently completely
unwarranted attack on people just trying
to buy provisions we're also seeing the
bombing of or the aftermath of a bombing
of a school in the eastern city of
kharkiv
that happening again yesterday as the
russians seem to continue to attack
civilian targets in the southern port
city of odessa that is a critical port
on the coast of the black sea uh we are
understand that hundreds if not
thousands of people now appear to be
packing up and getting out of there that
could be a sign that they believe a
russian assault from warships which we
know are in the black sea could be
coming soon although i understand from
some people i know who are in odessa
right now that at this moment it is
quiet that doesn't mean it will remain
so of course and meantime russian
president vladimir putin issuing the
most terrifying warning to anybody in
russia who is even thinking of opposing
him listen here to the president
but any people and even more so the
russian people will always be able to
distinguish true patriots from scum and
traders and simply spit them out like a
fly that accidentally flew into the
mouth spit them out
i am convinced that such a natural and
necessary cleansing of society will only
strengthen our country
a cleansing of society we literally have
not heard that sort of language from a
russian leader since the days of stalin
steve rachel bryan you're right jonathan
uh he also said the west is using
russian traders to create the civil
unrest on the streets of moscow and
elsewhere in russia as well hey jonathan
i wanted to ask you apparently six
nations have called for the united
nations security council to meet today
before a scheduled vote on a russian
resolution and the resolution
from the russians demands protection for
ukrainian citizens in vulnerable
situations that would be pretty much
everybody in ukraine
this resolution never mentions that
russia actually started the war
it's really kind of hard to believe when
you hear things like that steve but
russia is of course one of the five
permanent members of the security
council they have the right to put
forward any resolution
they want to they also have the right to
continually to veto any resolution they
don't like so you can see why a lot of
people believe that unite the united
nations is playing no effective role
here you have the country that started a
war an unjustified war an unprovoked war
able
to veto any resolution in the body that
was designed in the first place to stop
wars yeah it's extraordinary yeah and we
pay for that by the way we pay for the
u.n
go ahead bit brian um can we get our
money back
if you look at mikolav kharkiv uh you
look at uh
all these major cities what i find
astounding is despite the shelling
jonathan they have not given up
the russians for 10 days have not taken
a major city in the ukraine
how much is that due to their lack of
sophisticated weapons tactics and
communication and how much does that
have to do with the reorganized
resistance and communication of the
ukrainians
uh i think it's probably a bit of both
there brian certainly uh the russians
have been
organizationally inept if you talk to a
lot of military experts they have the
weaponry they have the air power they
just haven't used it in in the right way
according to a lot of generals that
we've spoken to and on the flip side of
that you have this fearsome ukrainian
defense the the ukrainians are extremely
proud people they have always said
nobody is coming in here and taking our
land they have repeatedly said they are
confident they have genuine faith brian
that they will win this war and they are
no doubt being helped by the supply of
weaponry the air defense systems the
javelin missiles the stinger missiles
that is being fed uh from western
european nations some of them coming
from the united states so they are
grateful for that help they always want
more of course but it is making a
difference the weapons that we the
united states and other nations are
supplying to ukraine
thank you jonathan great stuff